[Música]
há dois iguais
o taka né o jô rissóis processo de
reforma
na verdade luiza sua desculpa perguntar
quem não tem dinheiro quem acusou esta
tarde
não não quero gastar dinheiro que não
estava sabendo
olha qual hoje a mp roupa
pensemos que eu ia que coisa estranha
escolhidas no córrego
[Música]
parte do nosso passado
ae
[Aplausos]
sabem por que é que nós nos sentimos uns
verdadeiros produzidos por trabalhar
nestes contextos são complexos e duros
estamos convictos que temos a profissão
mais bonita do mundo
e porquê porque diariamente nos cruzamos
em ambiente hospitalar com os vossos
pais vós e vós os votos sendo inscritos
temos diariamente com o amor que vocês
recebem vossas casas e nós sentimos
privilegiados porque nem que seja por
cinco minutos
temos papel também encontramos
constantemente poetas populares como
falam do tempo a apanha da azeitona do
bilhar 1 milhão encontramos professoras
primárias de voltas que nos ensina os
nomes de todas as montanhas e rios
portugal
encontramos as vossas mães que repetem
constantemente o mesmo conselho para a
rua mas leva o casaquinho encontramos
músicos virtual do pessoal que nunca se
ensinar a tocar nenhum instrumento mas
levamos vários sítios do planeta
encontramos aquelas cozinheiras
talentosas cruz ensino aquela rosto pato
com eva cenoura couve e vai ao forno e
que nos deixou literalmente essa levar o
arroz nosso pessoal cruzinhas cruzinha
convido-os a viajar comigo este mundo os
mágico do trabalho do doutor palhaço
convivo diariamente com os vossos pais
que os vossos avós
nós muitas vezes não temos tempo
não damos um verdadeiro valor aqueles
que já têm muito tempo o senhor russo
mongaguá os filhos mudam
era assim que toda a gente no hospital
fria o senhor da cama e 15/8 cristian
todos os médicos todos informamos todos
os moradores dizem que a pequena que até
o papa já tinha o vasco é um dos nós
temos de falar porque assim é temos sim
mas morrinhos
imaginem que os três metros que vão da
porta do quarto até a cama daquela
senhora daqui um dia tinham 30 metros
imaginem comigo o corredor enorme negrão
seco duro e no fundo da poltrona estava
seco lembrar um cavaco silva
uns anos a dar e que não estávamos um
passo nos sentimos cada vez mais
pequenos
em vez de apostar na comédia no humor
optamos por chegar sentar dizer meu
amigo estamos aqui contigo
estamos aqui pra te partilha connosco
quiser falar e eu falou nós escutamos
ele falou nós ouvimos disse que toda a
vida fui maltratado plate natural e onde
eu trabalhava pessoal no bairro
em casa a família e os filhos no café os
amigos toda a gente tratava mal é que a
energia negativa negra se acumulava no
seu coraçãozinho
até que um dia energia explodiu
a médica passou passado 20 minutos e
ficou longe não estávamos na sua conta
de maio 10 mensagens negativas na nossa
conta do facebook zero
muitas vezes entre nós pensamos o
seguinte como a nossa juventude foi fema
sendo ronaldo com 30 anos e pajem feito
por futebol
uma modelo com 24 anos filar está velha
e o que é que estas mensagens trazem e
nós e os nossos entes queridos aos
nossos pais nossos avós saco meu avô ou
e velho com transplante cardíaco com 75
anos será que faz sentido gastar muito
dinheiro na minha avó com um medicamento
caro
e como é que eles vêem o amor já fetos
do sexo quando eu penso em sexo
da mesma maneira que eles pensam mas não
vou contar como eu imagino se eu tivesse
80 anos
imaginem comigo um casal o sexo pessoal
de aula
o casal o homem uma mulher e dois homens
ou duas mulheres como elas vivem o amor
é nestas cidades
imagina assim imagina um dia de inverno
o rio vão sempre a chover um frio ou
gelo que até os nossos ossos regem e eu
e minha bolinha
vamos para a cama quando essa botija da
água quente fazer é coxinha
pra mim é normal para mim é sexo
vou sentir aquela pina espinha com
exploding queremos o nosso primeiro vai
perder nada disto sol eu pego elas lado
por correio o corpo
esquece a mulher dos meus fãs
lembro perfeitamente
lembro me perfeitamente com os fãs hoje
era uma terça feira foi o dia em que nós
conhecemos
é rock era o do risoto enfermeira belita
eo núcleo os corredores do hospital e
curtiram o som mesmo a bombar pessoal
o melhor milhão pra quem não conhece
amanhã milhão que o filho é tua avó
maria milhão
[Aplausos]
nós colhemos essas músicas não porque me
agradam mas sim porque mexem comemora
destas pessoas fazem reviver momentos
bons ou maus mas fazem trabalhar a
memória
quando chegamos o quarto encontramos
três senhoras no quarto de banho sul
pagar inteira como solta um barco lógica
curtir o sol mesmo a segunda de ver os
pedágios cinco no ar tipo de gasto com
essa música não leva gelado 31
do lado esquerdo tava uma senhora pede e
osso magra fria como a neve e volta como
se fazia antigamente para a última
viagem
aquela viagem que ela se calhar ansiava
muito tempo passamos o volume da música
não temos que provar
encontramos interagem dos quatro mas
sempre à espera porque eu sinto é que o
corpo precisa de exemplos entre bateria
nos versos um sinal de repente sol pela
vida ligeiramente a cabeça por causa dos
dias onde as mulheres e suas mulheres
conseguem pescar e diz-nos baixinho
palhaço as estivessem nosso rádio elvis
presley
sal morraria agora ela pensa que o vírus
já os bryan dentro quando a música
terminou completamente nada para nós
completa muito aberta disponível ela
ficaria nos dias sabe seu jogo e selou
dissolvido
se estiver em frente
vocês vão salvar maioria só o rádio que
tem os três demos as mãos e convidados
teve comigo até o dia de hoje em um
castelo o índice extraordinário uma
escada em forma de caracol até o fim do
mundo um candelabro com velas e por
baixo daquela magnificando dinheiro quem
estava à nossa era bonita o vestido cor
pérola uma casa enorme
dançamos pessoal é termos dos pés
repente olhamos para ela aceitava ter
notado que nós passamos
estamos preocupados mas depois vimos que
não estava o ritmo da nossa música e foi
um documento aos nestes quatro anos que
nós trabalhamos com foco no chairs
muitas vezes buscam a nossa senado em
muito egocêntrico
estamos tão focados nas nossas agendas
como é que vai ser o meu dia como é que
vai ser o meu futuro e esquecemos muitas
vezes do outro
esquecemos que é super fácil ser feliz e
é super fácil fazer magia
basta quando chegou a casa junto dos
vossos pais de vocês e voz nos perguntem
a música tu queres para hoje o que
resolverá o que tu quer dançar comigo
hoje é simples pessoal vamos lá tentar
esse aumento tem que fazer uma pausa pra
vocês cada tipo alvo
quando chegamos já o serviço conhecido
exatamente com hora do almoço já
pensaram como a pergunta tão simples
como é o que é hoje o almoço pode nos
levar para imenso universo e primeiras
fantasias
a psicóloga que eu já acompanhava
naquele dia diz o seguinte quero e 23 a
uma senhora com azar mas já velhinha
está assim estão a viver há cerca de
dois meses que ela não interage não fala
praticamente não diz nada
quando entramos na porta do quarto
coincidiu com a entrada da colaboradora
trazia o almoço
pegamos no tabuleiro e fomos levar a
nossa menina que é assim que nós
tratamos uma forma carinhosa que as
mulheres gostam pensou eu que está tem
por meninas
quando levantei a 1 o tempo do tabuleiro
para ele é o dia o almoço era coelho
a reação brasileira foi muito estranho
imaginem os ossos no final do jogo do
sporting o que é outra vez
olhei para donizete antonio neto deu pra
mim
olhei pra donizete andrade neto ligou
pra mim e como que intuitivamente
propusemos o fim do jogo não vai assumir
que adora comer coelhos e eu vou estar
do lado daquela menina tão turbulenta e
os três durante o mesmo tempo precisamos
falar apenas e só com eles
apontamos o devo a dona exceto os dois
ea mesma voz dissemos como é que tú 30
quilos de gente o mestre de palhaça
consegue comer é que os animais tão
fofinhos enquanto estava no meio deste
jogo olhamos à nossa volta e vimos que
toda a gente no quarto estava a olhar
para nós parece custava o julgará nos
entendiam sentimos do lado de dentro da
cerca a brincar com os coelhos e
perguntei
é que nesta história tem razão nós
muitas vezes temos que está o ganho mal
nessa história não interessa o que
interessa é que o dia nós daqui um dia
sentimos um prazer enorme de rir de
brincar e temos 30 minutos a falar
apenas o coelho e final olhamos para nós
vivemos temos as calças verdes verdes de
cor da relva de tanto pular e nos
divertimos quando trabalhamos com
pessoas com vivência nossos filhos temos
ter a consciência de que o ritmo do
recife no de resposta deus diminui
drasticamente
nós vemos que os filhos mais os
familiares chegaram aos quartos pouco
ritmo frenético da nossa senado vai
superar ansiosos já não reconhece a mãe
nem o pai e não vêem a essência não
venha beleza que eu ser que já foi mas
que agora em ou não ser às vezes é muito
mais simples deixarmos a ansiedade
angústia não é fácil
a porta do quarto e chegar com suas uma
folha em branco
estarmos disponíveis fazemos perguntas
esperar pela resposta não julgar não
criticar amar isso faço a primeira
pergunta à mãe como está hoje e se faz
14 perguntas ea 14ª pergunta é como está
em minha mãe vai dizer eu estou bem
filha e na nossa cabeça que vamos pensar
em ter o equipamento ela não tá nem aí
quem não estava nessa história serei eu
estou super acelerado e não tem tempo
para responder
mostrar a ela que temos ferramentas
diferentes das minhas sócias pensassem
na história viva voz ecos falsos e voz
com os vossos pais mostrem o título que
vocês iriam dar essa história
imaginem comigo e peço por favor entre
dança e brinca
sim porque quando os vossos inscritos
partirem com os vossos pais vosso as
nossas mães partirem meus amigos só vai
sobrar apenas de sol
aquelas imensas e dolorosas soldados
[Aplausos]